they closed the case after only eight
months but
now portuguese police have reopened
their investigation
into the rape of an irish woman hazel
bean believes she was the victim of the
same man
who later raped an elderly american
woman
he is a german drifter known as
christian bee now the main suspect for
the abduction of madeleine mccann
this week in court police collected
their own archived files
and relaunched their investigation even
though
they once destroyed vital forensic
evidence
if you close the process because no
suspect was found then it means that
those foreign
evidence are no longer needed then the
judge must order them to be destroyed
but they
they might be needed in 5 10
15 years but thinking like that
we would be in a different way or in a
indirectly way violating our
principle constitution constitutional
rules and principles which is we cannot
have a database
of of biological evidence
hazel being was a holiday rep in pride
of russia in 2004
she lived alone at the complex where she
worked
her attacker climbed in through her
balcony while she was sleeping
in apartment 22 he tied her up gagged
her
raped her repeatedly and left her
bleeding
now the case is reopened we can't show
the police file
but it reveals detectives destroyed poor
quality forensic evidence
because there was no suspect hazel bean
told
portuguese police that her attacker was
white and slim with blonde hair and blue
eyes and possibly german in these
documents
it says the case was closed because
detectives had
no record of any potential suspect
fitting that description
but that wasn't true
five years earlier in 1999 the police
had photographed christian b
he was being extradited to germany for
child sex crimes
so he was in their files and he did fit
the rape victims description
if police do build a case against
christian bee it's unlikely he'll ever
be charged with rape
portugal has a statute of limitations of
15 years
madeleine mccann vanished in portugal in
2007
police are still waiting to interview
christian b
about her disappearance marty brunt
sky news portugal